there's a certain karma that's ripening
from ancient Egypt having to do with the
abilities we gained there remembering
regaining those abilities bringing them
to bear in our lives right now to help
the Earth as a whole right now
everything is intricately linked in a
larger energetic and spiritual system
that modern science has no concept of
they only look at the broken fragments
that appear into physical reality but
they no longer understand the larger
Matrix that the waves are in including
at the higher Consciousness levels
before a wave that created the physical
world even came to into existence in
ancient Egypt they knew an incredible
secret and that secret was the design
code behind everything in creation and
that this became expressed through
things like the hieroglyphic text there
are certain energy emanations coming
from certain hieroglyphs some of these
hieroglyphs have very powerful energetic
waves coming off them because of the
shape information it creates an
energetic effect